I'm pleased this evening to welcome
Jeanne gang back to Yale in this case as
xxxii Paul Rudolph lecturer the rudolph
lectures were endowed in 1986 by mr. and
mrs. Moritz
be enter shine to honor their close
friend who as chairman of the
architecture department at Yale was the
architect of the building in which we
now sit Paul Rudolph was the first to
deliver a lecture in the series other
rudolph lecturers include charles
Gwathmey Colin Rowe they're not Jimmy
Vincent Scully Paul Andrew Stanley Tiger
Minh and Robert Maxwell in fall 2013 the
paris-based architect Philippe Brahm
delivered the rudolph lecture as the
keynote address to the symposium
exhibiting architecture of paradox
tonight's rudolph lecture urging young
gang received her Bachelor of Science in
architecture from the University of
Illinois University of Illinois in
urbana-champaign in 1986 and then
attended the H a ha in Zurich on an
international rotary fellowship which he
followed with studies at the Harvard
Graduate School of Design where she was
awarded the master of architecture with
distinction in 1993 after Harvard
professor gang entered professional
practice first as part of the OMA in
Rotterdam and then at the office of
booth Hansen associates in Chicago in
1997 she founded the award-winning
practice studio gang which is
internationally recognized for its
visually striking work coupled with an
environmentally sensitive approach
through projects ranging in scale from
community anchors and cultural
institutions to tall mixed-use buildings
and urban design Jean gang
ferm engage pressing contemporary issues
and their impact on human experience
guided by this approach studio gang has
produced some of today's most innovative
and compelling architecture including
the recently completed arcus Center for
social justice leadership and aqua tower
both in Chicago honored and published
widely Jean gangs work has been
exhibited at the Venice architecture
Biennale the Museum of Modern Art in New
York and the cooper-hewitt National
Design Museum also in New York her first
solo exhibition building inside studio
gang architects sent attendance records
during its run at the Art Institute of
Chicago from September 2012 to February
2013 and was accompanied by an
exhibition catalog cope published by the
Yale University Press and the Art
Institute in 2011 11 Jeanne gang was
made a John and Catherine MacArthur
Fellow a highly prestigious honor almost
never given to architects qinggang is no
stranger to Yale in fall 2005 she was
Lois icon visiting assistant professor
of architecture the work produced in
that advanced studio was published along
with the studio work of other two other
con visiting assistant professors Sania
bald and Mark tsurumaki
in 2013 the work was published in 2009
in a book called negotiated terrains in
addition to our tournament Yale
professor Gannicus taught since 1997 at
the in still annoyed Institute of
Technology and his health appointments
at Princeton School of Architecture
Harvard's Graduate School of Design and
Rice University School of Architecture
please join me in welcoming Jeanne gang
back to Yale as she delivers this
evenings lecture getting real here
Thank You Dean Stern and thanks everyone
for for coming tonight and it's really a
big honor to be here to deliver this
lecture tonight I'm gonna be speaking
about our practice the types of projects
that we do and give you some examples
from the different categories of work
but also talk about the practice as a as
a design project in and of itself and
how we have created something that I
think is breaking new ground for
architecture and design practices this
this is a shot of some of the people in
the office we we work really closely
together as almost a collective of
architects and designers and really the
practice started out inside this small
office on the second floor in Chicago
and in a place called wicker park we
slowly grew in that space and to kind of
take over the whole floor and it's a
real urban center and Chicago very
vibrant you could buy anything around
there including a wig across the street
and we we've gradually almost outgrown
that space and and are moving into
another space across the street the
larger building we also work in New York
now and we have a small office there in
a very different environment where you
can also buy an American flag at the
site but the two offices work together
and and we collaborate across these
geographic territories I think the real
impetus for the office started from
taking Chicago as a specific context and
trying to understand the city many
people think of Chicago as a
quintessential American city given the
grid and the birth of the tall building
here but we also found many things that
were the
Side of Chicago the kind of the the
residual effects of the post-industrial
beginnings of Chicago in this view you
can see what you will find just outside
that neat Chicago Loop which is the
results of many years of industrial
operations the hill in the background is
not actually a hill it's a landfill and
you see the evidence of the polluted
sites all around around this city so it
became interesting to us to understand
this place also as an environment an
early project that we won when we first
started the office was the Ford Calumet
Environmental Center located right in
this territory so it kind of started our
research on these these post-industrial
sites one of the things we like to do in
the in the office is have events and
discussions about issues where we invite
people from different disciplines in to
have these discussions and and and
during one of these events which we were
really discussing environmental issues
we discovered a project and and
sometimes your projects don't just come
from clients sometimes their projects
that you can actually create yourself
and the result of of that beginning was
this really a book project the book
called reverse effect
we found out from our colleagues that
were in different disciplines around
environmental disciplines about some
serious issues that were going on with
the river and so we we dug into those
deeper through research and doing a
studio at the GSD about this and in
ultimately gained funding for for
publishing this this book to help the
public understand this as well so I
think one of our roles that we see
ourselves as architects as communicators
to the public
especially on issues that that involve
the city the Chicago River it was you
know the the they say that it was
reversed but essentially what that meant
was a series of 26 miles of canals were
built that took water from the lake and
and connected that water across a
subcontinent all divided in and
connected it ultimately to the Des
Plaines River in the Mississippi River
essentially flushing flushing the the
polluted water and the raw sewage away
from the city for health reasons but
down toward the Mississippi and the Gulf
of Mexico and so these these practices
that were really fine to do a hundred
years ago are you know are now very much
questioned as this this pollution
continues to go down and to contribute
to a dead zone around the Gulf of Mexico
some of the other complications of this
massive infrastructure project were that
there were suddenly invasive species
coming up this Mississippi River and and
threatening to enter into this Great
Lakes ecosystem which is is a very
originally a very closed ecosystem of
glacial water so the tough problem here
and I think it's one of the most
complicated things I think I ever asked
some students to think about was was to
think about a barrier which was being
proposed to kind of reestablish that
that Continental Divide reestablish the
difference between the watersheds and to
look what the opportunities might be
with that so and you know connecting
neighborhoods but also you know how does
it impact the the shipping system the
the invasive species that were coming up
that the Mississippi River are really
quite detrimental to tourism they tend
to jump out of the water when the boats
go by there they're very very large fish
carp fish that are about you know over a
hundred pounds very scary
very potentially ruining a tourism on
the Great Lakes they're also problems
due to the increased storms and floods
that are impacting people's basements
flooding in the basements and the water
quality is is really very bad and so we
decided to look at these problems and
think about what the potential could be
for this area and the lower-left which
is a part of the city that has lost many
of its factories and what could be
thought about for now and I think one of
the things that our practice does is we
work a little bit more along the lines
of like an industrial design company in
that we we really do our research and
reach out to people we interviewed a lot
of the users of the river the current
users to find out what what they were
actually doing along the river from
tourism to to rowing to entrepreneurs
and environmentalists in people actually
fishing and still eating the fish from
the river and so in addition to that the
the research through studio I'll also
help to flush out those problems that
students were really looking at you know
what the barrier could be could it be
something more than a barrier separating
these watersheds and as we developed the
the project and it started to become
clear what kind of projects this was the
real design part from from Studio gang
was really designing a series of steps
it was almost like a road map for what
the city could do to to tackle this
enormous issue and and and we we thought
that breaking it down would be the best
way to start understanding it where
eventually the solution is that you
would re-establish this separation kind
of capture the the used water recycle it
clean it using current and future
technologies and create this seer
of fresh water lagoons within the city
at the endpoints of these rivers and so
currently if the site looks something
like this we created images for the
public to understand what that really
could be like so this was the book was
really aimed not at other architects so
much but really aimed at the public
because there were some important
legislation that was on the table to do
with voting for a cleaner River and and
this really was set in motion to
coincide with with votes from the public
and what what's really interesting I
think is that you know as architects we
have the ability to communicate ideas in
in such a strong way taking technical
information from engineers and using our
imagination and creating ideas that
people can suddenly get inside and
understand so I think that's one role
that the architect is very well-suited
to play what's really interesting the
that the outcome of this book project
though ended up being the the first step
that we suggested so if you remember
back to the steps number one step that
we suggested was to acquire some of this
at post-industrial property for the for
the city and increase public access to
the water and that that was somewhat
controversial because many people are
saying the water is very dirty and it's
really not safe to let people access it
but the thinking was that they will
never people will never want to clean
the water or be part of the river unless
they have access to it and there's
public connection so after this book
came out we kind of became I know like
that experts on the river I guess and
them and soon there was an election and
the new mayor mayor Emanuel decided to
make the river a real centerpiece for
his term because the river really
connected through different
neighborhoods and
we and and another architect each were
asked to design two boat houses each
that we were doing - and another
architects doing - to create these
points along the river where people
could actually access the river for
boating for rowing so it was an example
of of something actually starting to
come to fruition and this project is
really came out well was very quickly
done and on a low budget but had has a
great feel to it and I think it just it
kind of gives me goosebumps actually to
see the the regatta going on now and how
people are suddenly engaging this river
and making it their own
these are inner-city youth kids that are
part of teams we looked at this motion
of rowing I mean the design of the
boathouse really wanted to capture the
motion capture the excitement and we
translated that into the kind of a roof
form two different trusses with the
elements in between transitioning so we
ended up with this almost like a warped
surface inside and you can see they
started using it even before the
building is finished as soon as the dock
was built all the elements are straight
so there it was very inexpensive and
then the plywood surfaces just create
the Warped surface there's an indoor
tank for winter rowing and you can just
see how this riverfront is suddenly
activated at this spot and that many
more people are suddenly able to to
claim this territory so what started as
a think tank I guess in our office ended
up creating something that is really
making a dynamic waterfront the words
that I've been using to describe what
and
this is something that we really just
love to do in our office are the words
actionable idealism actionable part
meaning we are looking to do things that
get built we're looking to make a
difference and we are idealistic because
you can't function if you don't you
don't think that it really is going to
change something a project that kind of
represents that I would say as well is
this nature boardwalk in in Chicago call
it at the Lincoln Park Zoo you know when
when the client comes to you and asks
you to design a pavilion one of the
things that we found is that you might
need to zoom out and think about what
the actual problem is and refine and
redefine what the program is
we designed a pavilion it was at a site
along the Lincoln Park Zoo where there's
there's a former well this building is
still there in 1908 cafe sitting along
pond there's only about three feet deep
it was a pond that was meant to be
picturesque and to encourage strolling
along the pond in this urban setting
however the three foot deep pond with a
concrete bathtub was really not
supporting much more than just the
reflection on the water and so when we
got the request to design a pavilion
here we assembled a team that included
ecologist and engineers and hydrologist
and we really started thinking about the
problem differently what we ended up
coming up with was really ripping out
the edge completely on this pond and
then redesigning the the pond itself to
be a water resource and a piece of
infrastructure so in instead of a three
foot deep pond at the bottom we really
started to and
an engineer the the overall site so that
we could claim runoff water and we would
clean this runoff water with plants and
along the edge and then allow this water
to become habitat it's also acting as a
stormwater reservoir as well so it's
preventing those flooded basements and
then it becomes almost an urban oasis I
don't think this kind of project would
work without exciting architecture I
mean that that is a key piece we're
really interested in wood as the
material the sustainability of it the
the kind of renewability of it and the
flexibility of wood the qualities of
wood the class I taught here at Yale had
to do with the materials qualities and
how do you express those and extrapolate
those this was done with a micro
laminated prefabricated elements so
they're all bent to the same size and
then these fiberglass pods that are
provide cladding and allow light to come
in so the the pavilion was really meant
for for educational purposes so students
could could use a space out of the rain
and study the pond life but it's really
become used for many other things like
you know if you look on line you can see
how many people are getting married
there especially architects and lots of
different kinds of classes and things
like that so but it's it's incredible to
how it has transformed the site over the
last few years with a very strong
increase in in biodiversity of the site
so they started there was a small
rookery there with about 40 black crown
night herons which has grown to become a
colony of about four hundred pair and
then there are also larger mammals
coming around at night the Coyotes which
are a very urban animal
they help keep the rat population down
but these are all animals that would
never be able to survive on just a pure
ordinary park with a lawn
dance members using the pavilion as well
so I think that that project does
represent some of the aspects of of what
cities could be and but it's it's
impossible to to think of cities without
thinking of you know the density that's
required and and frankly that the
residential buildings that are kind of
the DNA of the city and so at one point
in our office we were approached to do a
tall building for a residential building
in Chicago and we had to it wasn't
something that we thought we would be
you know we were doing many kind of
community projects and arts projects and
suddenly a tall building comes through
the door so it was it was really a
chance for us to think about what that
what that means for a city one of the
one of the key points I think for tall
buildings and residential buildings is
to think about the condensed footprint
and you know like many many cities are
different around the globe but the
condition here is really about trying to
densify the urban core and to reduce the
land that the land use that that happens
this typical pattern out in the suburbs
to reduce that that's for all that's
happening outside the city and in if you
do that you you find that a household
that lives in a dense tower in City
Center were close to jobs and close to
all the things that you need on a daily
basis is about seven times less in terms
of the production of carbon per year so
there there's a good argument for going
vertical and this is literally measured
there's also another aspect to tall
buildings that I think is very
interesting and that
and is a whole part of our practice that
really came from this very first tower
that we designed the aqua tower this is
a diagram that shows many of the towers
that we've designed since the aqua tower
in the in the very beginning at the
bottom you can see the these two options
there were two different options for the
aqua tower the one that was built and
the one that wasn't built and now it's
interesting to look at how the ideas for
towers are related to each other it's
very different than the kind of
community buildings because there are
there's there's a line of research that
applies specifically to taller buildings
and so some of these ideas the things
that are called things like solar
carving or mass customization or EXO
spacial or incremental stepping these
are ideas that are we are continuing to
work with in our tall buildings these
are some of the buildings that were
shown at the show at the Art Institute
that we had worked on
luckily the after well the aqua tower
was built and finished in 2009 and then
the economy tanked so many of the
projects that we had been working on did
not get realized and so we were able to
kind of use that time to develop a whole
series of ideas around the tall building
with with the aqua tower is an 82 story
tower that is residential and it has a
hotel in it and it was really conceived
of as a building that would respond to
its site very specifically and so that
initial drawings were topography of
hills and valleys that the hills would
relate to specific specific landmarks in
the city and that that people living in
the building would be able to connect to
those landmarks and to those unexpected
views the the topography was converted
and translated into
terraces this idea of indoor and outdoor
living which at the time I mean not very
many residential buildings were you were
embracing that the idea of the balcony
and and for us we I think internally we
all really liked indoor/outdoor and we
also felt that there would be a way to
enjoy to be part of the building but
also part of the city at the same time
that there's kind of this EXO spacial
character to this so every single floor
plate is slightly different and then
they they create movements up the
building so some of the some of the
terraces are up to 12 feet in depth but
for us it was always about creating a
community a community that could be even
on the facade of the building that
people could maybe see other people and
have a sense that there are other people
living there as opposed to the idea of
of making completely private selves that
would you know the only time you run
into someone is in the elevator which is
you know kind of awkward so it was
always the social idea it has become a
very social building there's a lot of
students from University of Chicago live
there a lot of people who lived in the
suburbs and are coming back into the
city and they want to enjoy the city and
it really just has this it's an outgoing
building I would say and and from from
the city from different parts of city
looking at it you know you the building
is strong enough to be able to handle
the the grills and the bicycles and the
decorations that people do put on their
balconies and I think it's something
that we welcome too because it gives the
city a sense of life that idea of the
exo spatial we're continuing as I said
to work with that in Miami who are in
the Design District we're working on a
new residential building there which has
these series of very deep baffles
that provides shading these are also
some through units and in within this
building so there is an environmental
approach and then this is from another
idea for the XO spacial a series of
balconies stems this is a building
that's under construction called city
Hyde Park and in this case the balcony
pieces are disengaged from the building
structure so that it performs better
environmentally when one of the other
ideas that came through from the tall
buildings was this idea of solar carving
the idea that we can make a building
relate to its context to the instead of
thinking of the building as an object in
and of itself maybe it's time to start
thinking about how a building relates to
the context around it in this case there
was a very important outdoor space the
High Line and we found that if we
followed the typical New York setback
rules we would be in doing it as of
right building we would be shading the
High Line and like for by using the Sun
to provide the the carving we're able to
bring about 200 more hours to the High
Line in terms of daylight and so it's
it's a bit counterintuitive but if you
think about the sight the the public
space in this site is really on the
interior of the block as opposed to the
exterior of the block so it made sense
to use the carving to bring light into
the center of the block as opposed to
deferring to the West Side Highway which
is right by the river so this this
building is under development and really
using the idea of solar carving and
another another idea that came from I
guess originally from aqua was this idea
of this incremental stepping which aqua
does and and we're using to a much
greater extent with this Bay Tower which
is in San Francisco
where the bays are oriented toward
different views
and rotate us as they move up the
building so I think the the interesting
thing about our tall building work is
instead of starting with a big form like
a gesture many times we're starting with
an element and so in the the current
building this is just a preview of a
building we're currently working on in
Chicago which is going to be the third
tallest building in the city and and it
started with thinking about a simple
shape an element that we could coax its
benefits from a frustum it's called it's
it's basically a truncated a pyramidal
shape and looking at this frustum what
the qualities are in terms of its
environmental qualities but also its
view qualities we started to build a
building around this idea connecting
three of these frustum together you
suddenly get a building instead of
having four corners it has eight corners
and it has a piece in the center that is
able to rely on outside pieces instead
of being itself structured so you know
it has flexibility in the center this is
some the models that we were working
with on this idea in the office and
stacking these frustums rotating them
and stacking them one upon the other
starts to introduce some better and more
benefits like confusing the wind and
reducing our wind or wind forces it's
it's a building that is located on the
Chicago River and along this what I'm
calling the one-mile access to the Field
Museum it's it's literally on axis with
the Field Museum without any other
buildings in in-between and but there's
challenges on this site as well here's
the Chicago River so we're looking at it
from the north three levels of
that block the site from from the actual
Riverwalk and here's the access coming
in so what we've been working on here is
is some things on the on the ground
level to extend the the pedestrian
connections between the park and the
Riverwalk
which you can see is you know kind of a
600 foot long stretch below some of this
raised
infrastructure so working with lighting
and programming to make that connection
stronger and and also bridging over this
site that was full of underground
infrastructure as well and so the idea
of lifting that center stem really came
into a necessity on this particular site
as we explore the site connections we
start to move into working with the
different different heights of these
towers is just the top piece and looking
at that so this project is ongoing
there's some really interesting
discoveries in terms of the solar we
found that the temperature was actually
higher on the smaller plates and so
we're relating our glass performance to
that discovery so we will have it's some
different performing glass different
types of glass in the overall building
and I think one that one of the things
about the tall buildings back to the
diagram is not just about the high end
aspect of residential high-rise living
in the city there's also a very strong
need to consider residential buildings I
think you know just for the life of the
city one project we worked recently what
was this an exhibition and that was
shown at MoMA and it was all about the
foreclosure crisis
so we were one of four architects asked
to reconsider housing given the
foreclosure crisis and and in light of
that is there a way that we could
rethink how to do public housing and our
project really it sewed together many
different strains of the research that
we've been doing in the office and we
are I'll show you the project and and
just the I think the exciting thing is
here that we are really looking for
testing some of these in the marketplace
as well and so the the whole idea of the
exhibit was to for us to really look at
what was happening in these inner-ring
suburbs so again focusing on a place
that we know very well I think that
there there is a temptation oftentimes
to to look far afield but there is so
much going on and so many issues right
in our own backyard we felt we knew this
area this is literally on the line on
the borderline of Chicago town called
Cicero where there were over a thousand
foreclosures and in during the the
economic crisis in the first year alone
I think it was in in 2010 and then
another thousand the following year so
it was really hit hard and again I think
starting with we always start with
what's there we really try to use our
observation skills to understand what's
going on here we found an interesting
piece of clue and evidence that that
many more people were living in the in
the bungalows than what they were
designed for these are the mailboxes
along the mughals and we you know we
really constructed a team that could
address some of these very sensitive
issues around foreclosure and and one of
the team members was a housing advocate
who was able to arrange interviews with
people who had
been through foreclosure and to ask them
about what was going on and what they
were doing and what what their jobs were
and we found out that through the
interviews that many people were working
three or more jobs and that you know the
the the the suburb of Cicero really
didn't need mass transit more than it
needed something more like a car share
and needed to help these residents find
ways to continue their work
Cicero really started as a city of it's
it's a suburb but it's a place of
emigration it always has been originally
from Lithuania Poland austria-hungary
but then today you know mainly people
coming from three states directly from
Mexico into Cicero and Cicero just does
not seem to have the infrastructure to
help people get started it's hard to
imagine but it at one point this Factory
in Cicero employed 40,000 people and and
those jobs just are no longer there the
the housing stock were these bungalows
made for single families the real crisis
I think wasn't that people you know went
beyond their means to to buy to put
money down on a house it really was
about loss of jobs many of the factories
closed and really there was a lot of
vacancy and typically what happens in a
place like this is that they'll cap the
the industrial sites with a clay cap in
a parking lot and then start orienting
everything toward the car again so it's
really about loss of jobs and not just
about foreclosure but it was really a
crisis as we look at how many homes were
foreclosed in Cicero and then this
industry that's also foreclosed so
together you have the industrial era
contamination and you have quite a you
know just
a lot of problems adding up and what we
were trying to do here was to see if if
the problem thing up could potentially
have a solution that would be that the
next phase of this place
starting with the housing you know the
20th century bungalow was really
designed for the nuclear family and
today we found that you know it's being
used and and inhabited by many different
types of families the way that the new
new arrivals coming in will sometimes
have family and friends living there for
a while sometimes single adults will
share housing together to get a foothold
and so the bungalow really isn't working
anymore so we we thought about taking
those different programs apart shuffling
them around and thinking of a new model
that would be a building that could have
a flexible continuity of space so as
your family changed you could you could
rent more space own more space and and
divide it up in different ways and so in
finding the the site for this project we
really looked to the factories they were
kind of the elephant in the room and
what if we could revive these factories
using phytoremediation
which many of them could be ready in
about four to five years this makes me
think of Mises image of the factory
where he had inside the factory
structure an art museum and and today
we're really thinking about like how do
we how do we pull these contaminants out
of the space how could we use the
materials in different ways engaging and
reusing the existing stock our project
started out as you know we begin with
this infrastructure we connect the
infrastructure using the the formerly
the trusses that were
used in the factory and then begin to
plug in units units that can be gang
together or rearranged in different ways
to accommodate this ever-changing family
and so this was kind of a theoretical
project but it was based on a lot of the
research that we had been doing I liked
the way that the new building just kind
of grows out of this factory like I'm
almost like a mushroom coming out and
and it doesn't reject height there's
there's still a desire to to bring
prominence to the house and so we were
really reinventing how this space would
work in terms of loops the ecology of of
the community combining living and
working and in these three loops of
water material and food interconnected
this was all like very idealistic but I
think one of the things that made it a
strong concept and something that can
still be pursued was the fact that we
looked at the economics of the situation
and looked to a different method of
ownership using a method of trusts and
also looked at rezoning the existing
Cicero suburb it blew our mind that you
know you wouldn't be able to actually do
this it would be illegal to have a
live-work space in a suburb such as
Cicero so we had to redact the code
one of the things that the economists on
our team brought up was that there were
that the amount of shared infrastructure
could be increased and we would we would
integrate the zoning but the shared
infrastructure could be co-owned by a
trust and then people would be able to
own smaller pieces which would make it
more affordable and we would bring in
the foreclosed homes in Cicero into this
network as well so people could actually
buy a space they would still own the
space they could put sweat equity into
the space but would it be a smaller
space as opposed to owning a suburban
home on a lot with a with a garage and
this this ended up being a project that
the city not Cicero but the city of
Chicago was very interested in testing
and and they actually are going forward
with a test of a cooperative situation
on some existing housing in the city and
so some of these things are you know
already being being tested and we're
really looking forward to finding a test
site now and and taking this further so
the steps were really to heel the site
to start settling the site and happening
it with this live work cottage industry
and then to start to grow the community
and and to interweave it back into the
existing fabric
I'm really thinking of also just that
the the existing fabric includes a lot
of people working out of their garages
and that would be emphasized so at this
point so I think I mean it kind of it
kind of goes along the lines of our
first projects that I was showing you
where there is this kind of actionable
idealism we're trying to find a way to
implement this in different pieces and
that's an ongoing project I wanted to
talk a little bit more about like the
structure of how our office is today and
and I think that's really interesting
given the way that architecture
practices have been in the past when you
think of the master builder the
architect was doing everything from
design to construction probably
financing working on raising money to
for the cathedrals and then how I think
mainly in the industrial era that
different design aspects were separated
out and became more specialized and so
we really see ourself and you know this
was the time where we see the architect
is the genius the individual genius and
so I think what we are proposing is more
of a structure of a collective of design
thinkers a creative team that is diverse
and able to bring in different
perspectives and I think that's been our
strength all along and it's really
something we draw on all the different
diversity within our teams and groups
even though I think we have we were just
taking in like 10% of our office or Yale
graduate so there's that that's a pretty
high percentage but you know you guys
are pretty smart we have a collaborative
atmosphere and and so as we've grown as
an office one of the things that we had
to deal was was figuring out the
structure and like I said in the
beginning that that became
design project in and of itself we had
consultants come in and tell us how to
create an org chart and I you know start
to create a ladder and we didn't really
like this this idea but we knew that we
needed some structure and so we worked
on it together
and we finally decided that it really
should be turned upside down and be more
like a tree and so that is our today
it's our supportive org chart is really
more like a growing tree that starts
with ideas at the ground and the roots
and then people are like branches that
support other people and that ends up
being a really a more representative
metaphor for the way that that we work
today
and so to close I wanted to show a
little project that was recently
completed that I think is hitting on a
lot of the ideas through the office the
attention to the concept but also the
materiality of the project and and what
it means for people it's the arcus
Center for social justice leadership
which is a project that we just opened
in October and it is in full swing now
it's on a college campus the small
college called Kalamazoo College in
Kalamazoo Michigan and you know you
might want to wonder what a Center for
social justice leadership is and we did
to actually here who was part of the
project was figuring out what that
should be but this is a campus where
there is a strong history of social
justice social justice activism they for
a long time have had programs for
students working on human rights issues
LGBT issues many different aspects of
social justice and they wanted to build
a building that would would house those
studies and be a center work
what could come and have conversations
and conferences about this these strong
important issues the college is very
small and most of the buildings on the
campus are there not all this beautiful
but they are traditional looking some of
them are new buildings that are meant to
kind of fit into this traditional and we
felt that strongly even though we're on
this campus that we really needed to dig
in further about what the social justice
program was and felt uncomfortable
associating the new program with some of
the plantation style and neo-colonial
kind of style of architecture what is
the space of social justice you know
oftentimes it is something that happens
as an event it happens in the street and
it's it takes on very organic forms we
were looking this was about the time
when we were in design we were looking
at Tahrir Square and seeing how people
self-organized into these these
different zones and and finding that
very interesting wanting to capture some
of that energy but if you look at places
where social justice is conceived in the
States a lot of times these are hidden
places a lot of times it happens around
a kitchen table or even in the basement
of a church this is the 17th Street
Baptist Church in Birmingham where dr.
King did a lot of his planning planning
with other people to March and so these
are places that are not seen at all and
so they weren't really giving us much
inspiration and we so we started looking
out to other cultures looking at
community meeting spaces meeting halls
what one common element with all of
these meeting houses
the kind of facing the center there's a
lot of times around a hearth or water at
the center the one on the upper left in
Mali is interesting because the elders
gather around here and they have a very
low ceiling so no one can get mad and
start you know yelling at someone else
as stand up everyone has to stay seated
at all times
so it kind of gave it a nice feel so
these were inspirational and then going
back to our site we were located really
close to this Grove
it's very isn't it's a remnant of a
savanna with oak in it and it just had
not been touched much at all it's kind
of a low area on the campus sitting
behind these small houses and this dorm
and the site had really a nice
connection to that we also connected to
a residential neighborhood and the
campus itself so we developed this kind
of three wings in the building that
would have a lot of transparency and
they're connected by these very soft
arcs that that create landscapes and
suggest scale here's an early early
sketch just showing how the the smaller
meeting rooms and the closed basis could
be within this thickened zone along the
wall and as the site developed and so
the these thickened walls became meeting
rooms cloakrooms
all the closed facilities kitchens and
things that support the central space
that can open up and become one big
meeting space so really ended up being a
project that was about convening and
meeting in different ways different
groups different amounts of people and
making it possible for the building to
act as one big space as well all
centered around hearth in in the center
that would be
the place to go and so as we as we
started to develop this further we
really needed to understand what the
material how who do we build it we found
that there was a great asset in the
Michigan area these white cedar trees
located this is the range of the white
cedar which is a wood that's really
resistant to rot and also bugs
it's a beautiful wood plentiful and
sustainably harvested and and one time I
think it was just on a site trip on one
of the team members came across this
barn and took a picture of it and and we
realized that there was there was a an
old tradition of building these barns
they were over a hundred years old and
they were made of wood so they're using
the wood like masonry so this was just
really incredible as a discovery and we
wanted to see if you know would it be
possible to to figure out how to do this
in the 21st century
obviously it lasts but it's also
incredibly you know sustainable
potentially we did find someone the guy
who is named Rob Roy who still builds
using this method and we took some
studio we went on a workshop with him
and these are studio gang team members
learning how to actually do it so you
know kind of do-it-yourself kind of way
still though you know how to commence an
institution that this kind of method
could work and how to upgrade it so it's
faster and make it you know 21st century
so we did our own mock-ups but we also
just we really connected with the idea
that the wood is unique each tree is
unique you know it's rings represent the
the weather in any certain year just
like people are unique and it really
somehow resonated with the idea of
social justice we wanted to do more with
it like so trying different things that
this technology offered like the
flexibility of the wall and we also
wanted to
you know use as little energy as
possible what we found though with this
cordwood masonry wall that really I
think the big discovery is the energy
balance because you know you're not
firing the material you're also not even
really doing anything to it you just you
just harvest it and then it has to sit
and dry for a year you can see how the
checking you turn the checks down so
that the water runs around it and
there's you know it's a really great
material so you're saving you're
sequestering you know you're basically
taking carbon out of the picture by
using this material so recently
completed it's it's got a worked really
hard to bring the aesthetic up to you
know kind of a more finished but very
very soft look by working with the
mortar colors and and working with the
scale and the tightness of the joints
you you have to work with the Masons
were incredible they did it so fast and
it was once you brought professional
Masons and we were able to do a lot of
things you know with technology using
including sorting the materials and
getting them ready to enter the site
inside it's very light it's it's nothing
about the wood really on the inside it's
just skylights that that help bring
light all the way through the building
these different sizes of meeting spaces
a kitchen something that really helps to
break down the barriers between people
is preparing food and you know many of
these ideas came directly from the
research and then the hearth in the
center where people can can gather this
in the cloakroom and the in the poche
area this is going out from the offices
and on the back wall here is installed a
piece of art that's going to be changing
every 2 years
by different artists that that focus on
social justice and the connection to the
Grove at one end so we were lucky to be
able to see this building in action they
had a conference as soon as we opened
which was really great to see and it's
incredibly satisfying to to have a
project that it will serve such a
purpose this is this is the I window
over here that that is the the bulging
wall that that allows light to and views
to get through into the one conference
room and then you can see in action
just like looking at the pictures really
and and finally yeah the the some of the
things like you know the window
placement you have to really work with
the proximate window placement not the
exact window placement into projects
such as this but I think it serves to a
lesson to tell us that you know there
that if even though it's incredibly
contemporary building and modern and in
every way that there might be ways of
building actually building that that
could be brought back that could that
could give us information about where to
go next and so with that I thank you for
coming and I'm happy to answer questions
as well so thank you
how did you get the masonary people to
do masonry with wood logs yes well one
one of the things that we did was we
invited the the contractors you know the
general contractors to the maison the
wood masonry workshop so first we
started by learning it ourselves you
know within the office having them come
to a presentation unit having Rob Roy
come to a presentation about his saunas
that he had built but then then we we
actually had the the contractors
representatives do a workshop and once
they saw the way that it was done they
really they got it so fast and and in
fact you know it was easy for them they
built the wall so fast and so well it
was it was really impressive they wanted
to and then I think a lot of times we
found that whenever you want to push
something technology-wise you you need
to get to the the actual subcontractor
that's doing it and not you know not the
general so we went you know directly to
the Masons and the Masons are skilled
and they wanted to take it on
well you know what I found is I think
developers are we're related to
developers architects you know again it
was like everyone was split into these
different categories of ways back and I
actually think developers are like
architects and they do want to do
something that's good
so but so it's really finding out I
think what you're you and your developer
client both want out of the project and
then in trying to you know get a common
focus and we never I think we never just
show up with you know here's here's the
idea and you know take it or leave it
it's really a process of sharing the
process and if you share the process
then the thinking moves together you
know so so the hard part is if like on a
recent project we worked through the
process together with one client and
then someone else bought the property
and it was so there's a different owner
so that that became a difficult you know
situation but I think we usually like to
show our work and that helps a lot with
so you know we might be thinking about
two ideas and and they're rough and we
we don't ever come in with a finalized
idea so it's it's it's getting a level
of trust and in an open-book process I
think is is the best way at least from
what we found so far
Bob mentioned that you worked at OMA
before going on to start your own firm
and so many offices that have come out
of oh ma you know run by OMA LUMS
seem to be characterized by shall we say
hellish office cultures and so I'm sort
of curious what did you take away from
OMA if not sort of that philosophy of
running an office I took I did have a
really interesting experience that I
domain and learned a lot about I think
the the ability I dia of reaching out to
those experts that you need early on and
like finding out who you want to
collaborate with but the office culture
was not one of the things that that I
went away with trying to replicate but I
think it's a it comes down to your I
think for me it was always about trying
to create a place where I want to work
and and the feeling of that place and
and so people that have the same similar
feeling about work and play in the
combination of those tend to find each
other and then it's just a it's a
creation not just of mine I think it's
it's a result of everybody's
personalities you know together so some
people have certain interests and that
can actually you know impact the way
that we do things as an office and it's
open and flexible and although it does
have the you know the hierarchy that
that is coming from the tree now but it
is it's something we work on a lot I
think we talk about a lot and
we try to make it be what we want it to
be I don't know if that answers it but
it it it's really trying to create that
environment where you feel you feel
comfortable saying an idea you're not
going to be shot down or you know the
ideas can come from anywhere we do have
to get stuff done so we work hard I mean
just like all architects but we try to
just you know have more fun doing it
but we do have martinis at camp but yeah
yeah yeah the way that research informs
I think it's with the very different
scales that we work on there are it's
the biggest challenge is figuring out
what you want to research you know
what's going to be relevant to that
project and you definitely will go down
and have tangents and blind alleys and
and things like that but we were
building a body of research as well and
one of the things that we're working on
is is the structure for how to access
the research that we've already created
in the office so that new people coming
in will be able to access it too so one
one habit that we have is for every
project there's a bibliography and so
the the bibliography starts Sunday one
and it gets added to you know sometimes
by our clients tell us what books that
they are looking at but what research
they're looking at and then you know
what happens oftentimes is the project
goes on hold and then you know it's a
new team is is coming on in two years it
starts up again so we always have this
when any person coming onto the project
has access to those initial things that
created the concept what was influential
and so anybody can get up to speed on
that research and so you don't feel like
you're coming into a project and like
now I just have to detail this you know
door or something it's it you really
have a chance to understand the
underpinnings of the project so we're
trying to find about more ways to do
that besides just the bibliography but
it is such an important part of our
practice that it's it's it's a it's a
key thing
okay all right
thank you